It's a great pleasure
to give this talk.
Thank you so much
for inviting me.
My name is Keshav Pingali.
I'm the CEO of Katana Graph.
I'm also a chair professor in
the computer
science department
at the University of
Texas at Austin.
And today, I want
to talk about
knowledge graphs, graph AI,
and the need for
high performance
graph computing.
Let me begin by
telling you why
we at Katana Graph feel there
is a great need for
high performance
graph computing.
Usually, when
people talk about
high performance computing,
they think about computational
science applications,
such as the design of aircraft
or the design of buildings,
for which people
use very large
clusters, like the stampede
cluster that we
have at the Texas
Advanced Computing
Center in Austin.
However, about ten years ago,
a group of, researchers,
including myself and and some
colleagues at MIT, CMU,
and other places,
realized that there was a big
opportunity to take
all of the techniques
that we had developed
in the context
of computational science app
applications in
high performance
computing and to use them for
doing high performance
graph computing.
And, basically,
there are two parts
to the argument
for why this is
a useful thing to do.
One having to do
with the volume
of data and
the other having to
do with time to insight.
So first, when it
comes to the volume
of data, we're
all familiar with
terms like the data tsunami,
the data flood, data deluge.
What all these
apocalyptic terms
tell us is that the world has
generated an enormous
amount of
data and is
generating even more
data at an ever
accelerating pace.
And so if you read documents
like IDC twenty, for example,
you find statistics like more
than half of the world's data
was created in
the last two years,
but less than two percent has
been analyzed.
To be sure, some of this data
that's being generated is
relational data.
You can represent
the data very
usefully as tables
or relations,
store them in
relational databases,
and then query them using SQL
and other time
honored techniques.
But what we find is more and
more of the new data that's
being generated
is what we call
unstructured data that doesn't
quite fit the relational model
that well. And a lot of this
unstructured data,
it turns out,
can be usefully represented as
a graph and then
processed using
graph techniques.
So that is the first side of
the argument,
the first part of
the argument about why high
performance graph computing is
essential, the sheer volume of
graph data that needs
to be analyzed.
The second part
of the argument
is time to insight.
In most application areas,
there's usually a window
of opportunity.
And if you can perform your
analytics on the data within
that window of opportunity and
obtain some insight,
then you can profit from it.
Whereas if your insights come
after the window
of opportunity
has expired, well, then the,
processing that
you have done,
the analytics that
you have done
are not very useful.
And so these are
the two reasons
why we believe
high performance
scale out graph computing is
going to be
increasingly important
as we go forward.
Just the sheer amount of graph
data that needs
to be processed
and then the need to process
that very quickly.
One question that we're
always asked is,
what are some of
the areas where
we see the use of graphs and
graph technologies?
This wheel over here tells you
about some of the areas
where we have,
seen our customers
using graphs.
And I'm just going to go very
quickly over some
of the highlights.
At the top right hand side of
the circle, you see
intrusion detection,
fraud detection,
large multinational defense
contractor that was interested
in doing real time intrusion
detection in
computer networks.
And the way they wanted to do
it was by building what are
called interaction graphs and
then mining these interaction
graphs to find
forbidden patterns
within these graphs.
So finding needles
within a big
haystack, as it's
sometimes called.
So that is one application,
fraud detection, anti
money laundering,
lots of applications there.
Another area where
we see graphs
being used increasingly is in
the identity
management space.
So one of our
customers ultimately
wants to go to a graph
with a trillion
edges, which is
very large indeed.
Even in more
conventional areas
that have been
around for a while,
like electronic
design automation,
so circuit design,
we see increasing
use of graphs
and hypergraphs.
So circuits can
be looked at as
graphs or hypergraphs.
The pins of
the circuit correspond
to the nodes of the graph.
The wires correspond
to the edges.
And it turns out that a lot of
the things they do
in chip design,
like static timing analysis,
logic synthesis,
placement routing,
All of them can be done very
effectively using parallel
algorithms of the kind that we
do at Katana.
The final area I mentioned is
medical knowledge graphs.
So precision medicine,
hypothesis generation
for drugs.
So here, the problem
is you have
a lot of medical data,
and you want to represent that
medical data in
one big graph.
And so this is
called a medical
knowledge graph.
And one of the customers that
we're currently dealing with
wants to be able to mine these
medical knowledge graphs in
order to generate promising
treatments for diseases and
equally importantly,
to rule out
potential treatments
for diseases before having to
go to the lab, do a lot of
expensive tests,
and then find out that that
treatment actually
doesn't work.
So these are just
some of the areas
where we see graphs.
There are, in
fact, many more.
So this brings us
to a data graph.
So what do we do?
Well, at the heart
of our system,
and I'll show you a cartoon
diagram of our system
on the next slide,
we basically have a scale out
graph engine that is optimized
for doing analytics,
for doing AI machine learning
on very large graphs.
So what we are
building is what
we call a graph
intelligence platform,
and it's been architected from
the get go to handle
massive graphs.
It's been tested with some of
the largest publicly available
web crawl graphs,
like w d c twelve,
which has a hundred and twenty
eight billion edges.
Our system has been designed
from the get go for graph
computing and not
so much for,
for being a graph
database unlike
many of the other
systems in this space.
And so we can do in
memory analytics,
AI, and machine
learning very fast.
And for some of the routines
that we have
implemented for our
customers, we're, like,
ten to a hundred times faster
than competing solutions.
Massive scalability,
we've shown that
our graph engine
scales to up to two fifty six
machines on the big stampede
supercomputing cluster that we
have at Texas. We also run on
all the three open clouds.
So AWS is your Google Cloud.
We are cloud first,
as they say.
And then the final thing that
we have in our graph engine is
we have native AI and
machine learning.
So we support a lot
of unsupervised
and supervised
training algorithms.
And then you can have your AI
and machine learning pipelines
that include querying,
analytics,
as well as third
party integrations
in your complete
workflow while
without leaving our system.
And I'll show you
some examples
of that as we go forward.
So here is the one click down
cartoon level picture
of our system.
So at the heart of it
is in the middle,
you can see
the scalable distributed
graph engine. So
it's got three
parts to it.
So the first part is CUSP,
which is a streaming
partitioner.
If you have a big graph,
it's usually where
it's at rest.
It's in AWS s three storage,
your Google Blob
storage, or somewhere.
So what CUSP does is if you
point it to this particular
graph that's sitting
in secondary
storage, and then you say,
here are the number
of machines
on which we want
you to partition
or shard the graph.
And then you could
also specify the,
sharding policy or
the distribution
policy. You can
even write your
own partitioning policy quite
easily using CUSP.
What CUSP does
is it then reads
in the graph from
secondary storage,
and then it shards
or partitions
the graph between
as many machines
as you have told it to do.
And then it builds
an in memory
representation of each portion
of the graph on each
of the machines
in your cluster.
Then the Galois
graph computing
engine kicks in.
So the Galois graph computing
engine is a shared
memory graph
computing engine.
It's got a bunch
of data structures
and a runtime system
that, again,
has been optimized for many
years for the needs
of graph computing.
Now anytime you
shard or partition
a graph, you need
to worry about
what happens at the boundaries
of the partitions.
You're going to need some
synchronization
and communication
in order to keep the data on
the different machines
in lockstep,
so to speak. So we support,
programming model
that's called
the bulk synchronous
programming model.
And the communication and
synchronization
that's required
in order to keep all
of the different
machines working together is
performed by
the Gluon communication
engine. This, again,
is a communication
runtime that
has been designed by us and
optimized for
the needs of graph
computing. So this
is essentially
the heart of our scalable
distributed graph engine.
This is our platform.
And as I told you,
we have shown
that it scales up
to two fifty six machines,
and it would probably scale to
even larger numbers
of machines
as needed.
We're exposing
the functionality
of this graph engine through c
plus plus.
So if you like writing
c plus plus code,
we give you a small number of
constructs, and
then you can go
write c plus plus code and
orchestrate the graph
engine directly.
And many of our
routines in our
libraries are
written that way.
But for data scientists,
we're also providing,
access to the graph
engine through
Python. So, again,
we give you a small number of
constructs, some of
our data structures,
and then you can orchestrate
the graph engine
directly from Python.
What we are doing on
this graph engine,
the libraries that
we are building
are in the space
of graph query.
So we support OpenCypher,
which is a query language that
Neo four j has popularized,
and we like it a great deal.
GQL is a new query language
that's coming out soon,
so we're going to
support that as well.
We also have a lot of graph
analytics routines,
so all of
the routines for path
finding and
community detection
between the centrality
and so on.
If you go to our website,
you can see a long
list of these
analytics routines
that we support.
We have some of the world's
experts on graph
pattern mining
working in the company,
and so we also have a lot of
graph mining
routines such as,
for example,
click detection or
frequent subgraph
mining routines.
And then, of course,
increasingly important areas,
so Graph AI. So we have both
supervised and unsupervised
learning algorithms.
And as I was saying,
you can build
an entire AI machine
learning pipeline
based on our system,
as I'll show you later.
We run on CPUs as
well as GPUs,
and we could
easily extend this
to FPGAs as well,
although we haven't found that
much of traction
in the customer
space for FPGAs yet.
So now let me double
click a little
bit and tell you
about knowledge
graphs in a little more detail
in some of the verticals that
we are engaged in.
So we're engaged in
three verticals,
pharma, financial services,
and information security.
And what I want to show you in
the next few slides
is basically
what these knowledge
graphs look
like or what these graphs look
like in these areas,
and then the kind
of graph AI,
graph analytics
that's required
in these domains.
So first up is health
and life sciences.
So here, as I was
telling you earlier,
people want to build these big
medical knowledge graphs.
And the nice thing
about graphs
is that they can represent
entities of many
different types.
So graphs have
heterogeneous nodes,
heterogeneous edges.
And this sort of cartoon graph
over here shows you
nodes for drugs,
a node for a molecule,
a node for a target protein,
a node for a side effect.
So all of these are entities
that have different types.
They can have different kinds
of properties,
but they can all
live together in
the same graph,
so to speak. And
then, of course,
the edges also have type.
So you can say
a drug has a certain
structure, which
is this molecule.
A drug has a certain
side effect.
It's associated with
certain proteins,
and so on.
Another nice thing
about graphs
is that they can represent
information at many different
levels of abstraction.
So for example,
a given chemical molecule has
a given chemical
structure that
the chemists know,
and you can represent that
chemical structure
itself as a graph.
And so that chemical structure
of this molecule can live in
the same data space,
so to speak,
as but drug and proteins,
drug side effects, and so on.
So data at many
different levels
of abstraction can all live
together in
the same data space
if you use graphs.
So what are the use cases that
we are seeing? Well,
I was telling you
about a medical,
a pharma company that we're
working with that's
growing drug
hypothesis and discovery.
Another area that we're very
actively engaged in is in
precision medicine,
and I'll tell you
a little more
detail about that in the next
few slides.
Another place where graphs are
used extensively
is in financial
services or fintech.
So the idea here is to take
financial transaction data and
then represent that as a big
heterogeneous graph,
and then basically
do analytics,
AI, mining, and so on on these
graphs in order to do things
like fraud detection,
identity theft,
customer three
sixty, and so on.
So if you look at this,
small graph over here,
it's showing you a client,
and then the client
has an occupation.
The client has purchased
some services,
client owns an account,
the account has
been invested in.
And and, again,
the key thing to take away is
these are big heterogeneous
graphs where the nodes have
different types,
each type has
different sets of
properties, and then the edges
themselves have different
types as well.
And that is the kind of data
that can be represented very
conveniently using a graph.
And then what we need to do in
this particular
area is to feed
these graphs into traditional
machine learning
models in order
to do things like
fraud detection
and so on.
The final kind of knowledge
graphs I'll show you are from
the information
security area.
So I was telling
you earlier that,
we worked with a multinational
company on real time intrusion
detection and networks.
So here is, interaction graph
that was actually built by our
system for this
company over a period
of time. And what you notice
again is that there
are different
kinds of nodes.
So, for example,
there are websites.
There are nodes
for processes,
nodes for files, for
ports, for users,
and so on. And if,
for example,
you read a certain file or you
write to a certain file or you
fork a process and so on,
all of that activity can be
represented very nicely using
a graph of this sort.
And then
the intrusion detection
problem that we
solved for them
was looking for
certain forbidden
patterns within this graph.
I don't have the time to tell
you about
the particular pattern
that we detected,
but the highlighted edges in
this graph were a forbidden
pattern and that
was highlighted
and then reported
to the operator.
So that is the data.
All of this data
in these domains
are being represented using
graphs or knowledge graphs.
Now what we need
to do in order
to do the analytics is you can
have supervised learning,
unsupervised learning.
So we support
unsupervised methods
like Louvain clustering,
page rank,
betweenness centrality,
which is very important in
security applications,
as well as supervised learning
algorithms like
GNNs and GTNs.
And, again, you need high
performance scale
out processing
because the datasets in these
worlds are very, very large.
So you could have hundreds of
billions of nodes
in these graphs
with hundreds of
billions of edges,
and then you need to do all of
this processing very fast.
And so I'm making the same
argument that I started with,
earlier in my talk,
except that now I
made it a little
more concrete by
giving you a bunch
of use cases and,
showing you what is
done with that data.
So here is a slide
that goes a little
more into this pharma use case
that I was, showing you.
And the takeaway from this
particular use
case is the need
for an integrated
system with querying,
analytics, AI,
all built into
the same workflow.
So let's take a look
at what this is.
In this particular company,
they had a big medical
knowledge graph,
and then they
gave us a query,
which I've shown in
the bottom right.
The query says extract oral
drugs and associated
targets for
heart failure treatment,
return the top ten chemical
compounds most
similar to a given
compound, such as
benzene in this case,
and return their targets.
So what is done
is to take that
English language
specification,
and then that gets translated
into a small graph that I've
shown at the left
in my diagram.
So you have this big graph,
which is the medical
knowledge graph.
That's called the host graph.
This is called
the query graph.
And then one of the key things
that you need to do to process
this query is to find all
instances of this query graph
in this big medical
knowledge graph.
So each instance
corresponds to a hit.
Let's call it that.
And so you basically return
the list of all the hits that
you got for this
particular query.
Then the next
thing you need to
do is to take all
of these hits
and then find
their similarity.
You need to give a similarity
score to each one
of these hits
using a particular similarity
metric that's called Tanimoto
similarity. Now
this is something
that's implemented
by what they
call a chemical cartridge.
So these are just routines,
libraries that they use.
We're not going to
reimplement them,
but basically, this shows you
that when you
build this kind,
what you need to be able to do
is to do already
integration of
these kinds of third party
packages into your
overall workflow.
Now since you have a bunch of
hits and you can compute their
similarity scores
in parallel,
one of the nice things that we
can do in our
system is that we
can compute
the similarity scores
themselves in parallel
using our engine.
And so this chart at the top
shows you scaling
for computing
tiny motor similarity
on a shared
memory machine.
And as you can see,
you get very good
scaling as you
increase the number
of threads.
Once you've got the scores,
the similarity scores for all
of the hits, you sort them,
and then you return
the top ten.
And so what you see over here
is a relatively
complicated workflow.
We work with far
more complicated
workflows. But even
in this example,
you can see the need
for querying.
You see the need
for integration
with third party packages,
such as these
chemical cartridges
like RDKit.
And then you see the need for
doing ranking and other kinds
of algorithms.
So let me end by telling you
about a few use cases.
So this is GraphAI
in the real world.
This is some work that we're
doing with one
of the biggest,
fintech companies
in the world.
So they want to handle massive
datasets with
billions of nodes
and edges. And they
gave us a bunch
of problems, and I'll show you
results for two of them.
One of the things they wanted
was a page rank computation,
and then the other
is a unsupervised
learning algorithm
called Louvain
clustering, which is basically
a community
detection algorithm
that builds hierarchical
communities,
and that's very popular now in
the machine learning world.
And so the chart
below shows you
some numbers, for two
different graphs,
a small graph with a hundred
million nodes and
a bigger graph
with twenty billion nodes.
And, we're also showing you
the number of machines we used
and then the time to compute
page rank and Louvain.
And these are substantially
faster than what
they were able
to do on the system that they
had been using
previously before
they started working with us.
Here's another application.
Lots of interest
in this area.
So molecular property
predictions.
So here is the way to think
about the problem.
I have a bunch of molecules
whose properties I know,
And these properties could be
at many different
levels of attraction,
so they could be
quantum properties,
physical, chemistry
properties,
or even physiology
like whether this particular
compound is toxic
to human beings
or not. So whatever these
properties are,
the way to think
about the training
data in this case is that you
have a collection
of molecules,
and each molecule is labeled
with a property.
And then the inference task is
given a new molecule whose
properties you
don't quite know,
well, can you predict
what the properties
of this molecule are given all
of the training data
for the molecules
that you do know?
So this is a very
important problem.
Lots of interest
in this area.
There's
a benchmark competition
that's called TDC benchmark
competition that
lots of people
are entering now.
And, recently,
some of our guys
came up with a innovative way
of using graphs in
this particular area.
So given a bunch of molecules
and their labels,
what they actually do is to
build what they
call a molecular
similarity graph.
So in the molecular
similarity graph,
each node corresponds
to one of
the molecules, and then there
is an edge between
them if they
are similar in
their properties
according to some
RDKit measure.
So you can think about this as
representing similarity
of the different
molecules that
you have in your
training data. And the node
features come from the Katana
Life Science module.
So what we do
with this labeled
graph is that we
use a g n n in
order to create vector space
representations for
each of the nodes.
So we embed each of the nodes
in some high
dimensional space.
And then given
a new molecule,
we basically use these learned
embeddings in order
to do the prediction
. And we were able to improve
the leaderboard by
about six percent,
in with just about
two weeks of effort.
So what you can see is what we
are doing is inventing
new algorithms,
new ways of thinking
about problems,
AI machine learning problems
using graphs. But then we also
have this very nice platform
that we can quickly implement
these new algorithms
on and then
see how well they do.
Here's another
application from
the precision medicine area.
Lots of VC interest
in this area.
Lots of companies
working in this area.
So here is
the precision medicine
problem at a very
simple level.
Right now, if you
have a disease,
you go to a doctor,
chances are you
will get pretty
much the same
treatment that he
would have given to some other
patient who has
the same disease
that you have.
What we would like
to do, obviously,
is to be more precise about
the treatment that we give you
by exploiting things like your
medical history, your
genetic profile,
everything that's known about
your family, your financial
circumstances,
your environment,
and so on. And so what we need
to do is essentially
get a patient
three sixty information,
so to speak,
about each patient
and then use
that information in order to
direct the treatment
that we're
giving you for
a particular disease.
So we are working with one of
the big precision medicine
companies in this space,
and here is how they
want to do it.
They want to take
all of the data
about a patient and represent
that data as a graph.
So for in your training set,
you have a bunch of patients,
and so you've abstracted each
patient out into a graph.
And then for each patient in
your training set,
you know whether the treatment
has been successful or not.
And so you can
label the graphs
in your training set with that
particular label.
And now the problem
is the following.
If a new patient comes in,
what we do is we build a graph
corresponding to the data for
that person, and then we infer
the label for this new graph
based on everything
that we know
from the training set.
So this is basically what's
called a graph
classification problem.
And, again, we're using state
of the art techniques in graph
transformer networks and graph
neural networks in order to
solve this particular problem
using AI and machine learning
techniques. This is,
some recent work on graph
transformer networks.
So this is something that we
developed for the precision
medicine use case.
And, I'm not going
to go through
the details of
the running times
and accuracy,
but I want to make two points
using this slide.
The first is that we were able
to improve
the running time over
previous algorithms for GTNs.
And the way we do it was by
inventing a very new algorithm
that uses sampling
without losing
accuracy. So developing new
algorithms for
these graph machine
learning problems is one of
the things that
we do at Katana.
And then again,
as I've been emphasizing,
we have this this platform on
which we can quickly implement
these algorithms
in parallel and
see how well they do.
This is my last slide.
I want to conclude by telling
you about something
that you all know,
and that is that
knowledge graphs
and AI, at least
in our opinion,
are the next base big thing.
So this whole
area of analytics
started out with what we can
call descriptive analytics.
So this was the old style
analytics where basically
you just said,
what happened?
So you said, I had,
pain in my chest,
and there was a shooting pain
down my left arm.
That's what happened.
Diagnostic analytics
is the next
more sophisticated
kind of analytics.
So here, what we want to do is
to also say why
something happened.
So it's not just an account of
what happened, but also you
probably had all
of those problems
that you described because you
were having a heart attack.
So that is diagnostic
analytics.
The next more sophisticated
analytics is
prescriptive analytics.
Given that these things have
happened and given
that this is
why they probably happen,
here are all
the things you need
to do in the future
in order to
mitigate the bad effects of
whatever happened.
So here you
obviously need some
predictive models in order to
be able to say
what needs to be
done in the future.
And then
the most sophisticated
thing is what we
call predictive
analytics. And in
predictive analytics,
you're not really
building models
based on rules or
something that
people give you,
but you build the models
automatically using
all of the big
data that you have and all of
these wonderful
machine learning
and AI techniques that are
available to us.
So that is where
there is going
to be a lot of action,
predictive analytics.
There are many
kinds of predictive
analytics on different
kinds of data,
but we believe
graphs are going
to be a very big
part of predictive
analytics. And
that is the space
that katana graph plays in.
With that, I'll conclude.
Thank you for your attention.